[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
>> I STOOD BY YOUR SIDE THIS
WHOLE CAMPAIGN, YOUR BEAUTIFUL
DUTIFUL MELANIA.
I CAN'T TAKE IT ANYMORE.
I AM YOUR WIFE.
>> YOUR DAUGHTER.
>> YOUR MOUTHPIECE.
>> YOUR ONE BLACK FRIEND.
>> YOUR OTHER DAUGHTER.
>> AND YOU'RE TAKING IT FOR
GRANTED THAT WE'LL ALWAYS BE
THERE.
>> BUT ONE DAY SOON, DONALD, YOU
MAY WAKE UP AND THIS BOMB PUSSY
BLOUSE WILL BE GONE.
♪
♪ ♪
♪ DONALD I'M NOT SORRY ♪
♪ I'M NOT SORRY ♪
♪ BETTER STICK WITH YOU UNLESS I
THINK WE'VE GOT TO -- ME AND MY
LADIES BACK ♪
♪ FIX YOUR BALD SPOT ♪
♪ I'VE HAD ENOUGH ♪
♪ TIRED OF THINKING ABOUT YOU ♪
♪ I'M DONE THINKING ABOUT FOUR
FINGERS UP ♪
♪ THEY DON'T BEND RIGHT ♪
♪
TELL THEM HELL NAW
DADDY HAS TWEETED SORRY ♪
♪ I DON'T EVEN THINK HE
MEANS IT
I'M SUPPOSE TO BE THE BRAINS
HERE ♪
♪ WHAT THE HELL HAVE I BEEN♪
THINKING
NOW HE'S BRINGING
PAULA JONES IN ♪
♪ THERE GOES MY FRIENDSHIP WITH
I MISS CHELSEA CLINTON
CALL ME CHELSEA
I'M DONE THINKING ABOUT ♪
♪ YOU
I'M DONE THINKING ABOUT YOU
FOUR FINGERS UP
TELL THEM HELL NAW ♪
♪ I KILLED ON THAT
CONVENTION SPEECH
NO LIE
BUT I'LL NEVER BE IVANKA ♪
♪ IN YOUR EYES
I DON'T GIVE A DAMN
TONIGHT I'M TURNING TABLES
DON'T CALL ME ♪
♪ TIFFANY TRUMP
I'M TIFF MAPLES
I'LL LEAVE MY RESIGNATION
IN THE HALLWAY ♪
♪ SIGNED ON THE WHISLE
THERE'S NO LAST NAME
NO LAST NAME
I AIN'T -- WITH NO ♪
♪ LAST NAME
DON'T GET ME WRONG I HAVE
GOOD LIFE
BUT DONALD DOLL DON'T ♪
URNT ESTIMATE YOUR WIFE
I GOT AN EASTERN EUROPE MIND
SET
I WON'T FORGET ♪
♪ DONALD BETTER WATCH OUT
WATCH OUT
ME AND MY -- ABOUT TO WALK
OUT ♪
♪ I SEE MY PANTS IN THE
CORNER
LOOKING FOR THE BACK DOOR ♪
♪ YOU ONLY WANT ME WHEN I'M NOT
THERE ♪
♪
WITHOUT ME YOU WOULDN'T BE
STANDING THERE
YOU'D JUST BE THAT GUY ♪
♪ WITH THE WEIRD HAIR
♪ YOU'D JUST BE THE GUY
WITH THE WEIRD HAIR ♪
>> I WROTE THAT ALL BY MYSELF.
>> THE LIMO IS WAITING.
LET'S GO, YOU LOOK VERY NICE.
BUT LET'S GO.
TIFFANY WAIT HERE.
>> OH, COOL.